originally for assessing students skills
development and critical thinking and
problem-solving
they approach these tests holistically
there's actually three parts of the CLA
but we're only interested in one part
there's making argument that you can
argue that there's wonderful performance
dances the performance tasks are
somewhat similar to case studies but you
have are a set of documents that are
provided to the student the documents
are not going to the best documents
they're deliberately designed to the
mixture of relevant irrelevant
misleading
sometimes structure to take the students
off to catch information and the
students actually have to sift through
the documents can hear them against each
other
see which one's favorite some of the
documents are going to collide some of
the documents will also contain
arguments that the students have to
identify so you have a document library
that can range anywhere from two to nine
documents and documents are going to
continue data different types give them
the students sometimes just to wean them
away from over reliance on qualitative
anecdotal information as opposed to
actual statistics so the documents
themselves are what basis and you have a
scenario in this scenario you have to
take a role that's why it's similar to
what John was describing the problem
based learning you are placed in some
sort of position you have to make some
sort of policy decision can be adapted
very easily
leadership instructional leadership yeah
I have to ask later on what was the
difference between those two let's see
so the the CLA you can use it with
almost any scenario I've actually helped
instructors develop them for art classes
stretching the scenario sets the student
in a situation where they have to make a
decision usually it's in response to
some other people those advocacy of this
policy of that policy so they're
evaluating other people's arguments
they're evaluating other people's use
the information that's being provided at
them and we try to build in things again
to offer the students opportunities to
identify when people are using
information incorrectly the other thing
that the students have to do they're
given these prompts so you have
documents scenario now you have the
actual questions with their details and
the questions require them to write
essay responses and the essay responses
ideally are not just going to include
this person's right this person's wrong
you're gonna put justifications that
refer to the documents so the stress is
on moving away from opinion based
argumentation to evidentiary waste
yeah the CLA is one to beat my tool for
doing this the other component of the
CLA urge the students don't usually see
when it's being used solely for
assessment in which they do see if we're
using it for pedagogy is the rubric and
CLA rubrics there they have changed over
time one that John was working with this
is an older rubric before our
performance task Japanese
well this is a somewhat different
presentation and you're probably coming
in for our colleague gray did show up so
I'm getting sort of impromptu discussion
furnaces
the rubrics evaluate certain skill areas
they break it down to three different
sort of blocks emerging developing
mastering and there are subdivisions
within each of those the newer rubrics
actually scores from one of six at each
one it's very clearly differentiated and
CLA people construction and these are
very usable Juwan has adopted them into
her classes they have a generic rubric
and then you can put tasks for
discipline specific that you're looking
for the students the matrix of generic
rubric so that's what a CLA performance
task is to give it to your students they
sit down they go through the documents
you may have them writing it out by hand
you may have them doing it out of
computer sometimes I use them as
take-home assignments
ultimately what they're doing is they're
generating responses to what
writing skills they have to exercise
their critical thinking skills both
analyzing other people's arguments
finding whatever flaws are ready
handling information and also making
their own arguments and they have to do
the broader scale of the problem solving
they have to actually say this policy is
the better policy and here's why and
some of the situations may actually be
set up in such a way that they shouldn't
actually say that one policy is better
than the other if that's the case they
should say why why they can't they get
one part of the rubric actually has them
looking to see whether there's anything
that's been left out so that's part of
the problem solving matrix
you have any questions about that
approach how attacks it it's very
adaptable methodology it takes there is
a learning curve there's quite a bit
involved with the officials CLA people
running CLA performance task academies
but those are serviceable but a bit
actually applying them to classes we
learn a lot of it on the job source
we started working with it in 2005 and
the reason that we did this is when the
CLA were still fair with you we did have
a review our core curriculum and we
decided that the CLA didn't really know
what we were getting into it but one of
the things we liked about it was this
value-added focus all here familiar with
the need to justify what we're doing to
external agencies citizens to the
government and show them that we're
actually adding some value so what were
we going to try to add value quality of
these these key skills critical thinking
decision making and writing and why
though as well quite frankly those are
the ones that employers are asking for
the most and those are the ones that
they're asking for precisely because
most of our graduates don't have the CLA
we participated in a study and the
minister
our the first time that we did it is
2005 to 2007 the official results there
are a lot of results but this is just
sort of the most easily explicable ones
but they show is that our students are
making some improvements so they were
happy you know the rate that we wanted
them to but that means that it means
that our students are being left behind
because our students started out so if
they were already in beginning the race
you know several steps behind some of
the other people who were they ever been
compete with the marketplace if we just
did what we were doing they were going
to be at a disadvantage so what we did
is we brought in the CLA in the
classroom and we started a lot of issues
we were a pilot site with the CLA in the
classroom we did some more assessment
with these longitudinal studies what's
more interesting with the shows of that
after we sync the resources the time the
effort the thought into faculty
development with the CLA and infusing it
into a classes the sort of project that
you want flowers detailing earlier we
had different results again this is not
measuring just where our graduates were
who was measuring their rate of
improvement so their rate of it for men
was well the waffles expected so putting
all this effort into CLA the faculty
development and paid off in pretty
remarkable increases in critical
thinking writing starting up high now
they actually have a chance
playing field when they get out of the
workplace
that's what we did in fall 2008 we
launched a lot of different active
development efforts aimed at the use of
CLA in the classroom Brock and the CLA
people to do the workshops get support
regarding the corporation 99 that is he
participated at the first workshop 36 of
them went on to develop see a little bit
faster assessments with people from all
different fields so we were the man and
we've got those reports available in our
digital Commons we produced a CLA
workgroup which is still active and the
CLA work group is tasked with trying to
figure out exactly how we're going to
infuse the clas by its academic units
started to adopt this we're both from
the department that has actually done
most with it
I'm from the unit that's done mostly
with the philosophy because we teach you
a critical thinking class so we actually
adopted the CLA for our sax assessment
as one of our measures
our QEP right now for the one we're
developing is focused on critical
seconds and exactly where it's going to
go is a little bit of easy it's clear
that the CMA is going to be a major part
of it but we're at the stage quite
frankly where people are throwing a lot
of different things on the table and I'm
not clear myself you know I'm not fairly
low level decision making when it comes
to those sort of things well they're
gonna decide all they know is that were
focused on critical thinking we we just
decided that the outcome that they want
to focus on is critical thinking
as demonstrated in two major disciplines
not just
government history we have five
different disciplines atmosphere
political science philosophy history and
geography and intelligence studies and
we've actually put the CLA measures into
our operational plan University College
which doesn't call the in-processing of
our refreshment and he handles the core
assessment they have also used the CLA
pretty extensively and then a lot of
individual faculty and other departments
have used the CX of some people in
English have used it but the English
departments not
the apology well I've actually been the
coordinator for the rising junior and
entering freshman CLA exams but that
only tells us about these colors it's
difficult to compare the performance
tests directly against each other where
we currently are because the official
CLA it's the same pool of graders and
they all are high level competency
ratings quite frankly we're building
from the ground up some graders are very
good so I can compare myself I would
feel comfortable to my results from my
class
but institutionally what we're doing is
we have a mentoring freshman provide
space for how they're different here
rising juniors protects some trouble
with compliance going to collection do
it because we've made a voluntary test
but now it's going to be indexed to go
into a major and then exiting seniors in
the majors
so what that means is will happen pretty
soon because work implies to work it
applies to thing what's up what is your
thing we have to have a first draft
written I think December this century
that starts in I think enable you know
this has been in development I haven't
been involved i softly so we already
incorporated stealing assessments are in
place
presentations of this there's no music
for assessments we have these examples
that test calls now we're leaving some
students out right that transfer
students we don't test phones so we
don't know how they're doing we do
individual assessment classes the right
engineer exam that was the first one we
converted it to a silver when the past
Buddhist see things you know
standardized tests and we may get any
useful data from nobody had actually
used it trying to improve classroom
instruction we switch to the rising
junior exam being a CLA and we did it
two different tracks because some take
the national CLA and we use those to
compare against those who took the
national Sealaska Thunder crashing and
then we actually developed our own
institutional
we developed our performance to ask
faculty administer it rated there are
some as far as I'm concerned there's
some questions and then we'd be
reportable then actually our rise for
junior report is available in our
digital Commons as well where the
national supervisor extremity yes I mean
the numbers I don't know exactly how
they come up with what I know is when I
look at our students scores in relation
to the performance tests we actually put
pro array themselves I can tell where we
are and where we are right now but
frankly as students that have been
events but as we put more in the more
steel any like assignments that again
like those models talking about into the
curriculum that has we need to introduce
them to rubriz and as we tell them okay
this is what critical thinking skills
consistent this is what handling
evidence consistent and we just keep
going at over it and over and over it
there's four sugar if they don't
this is this is kind of an interesting
chart I'm a visual learner myself so I
like charts I didn't make this chart
this is something I'm pro bono but if
details were do it we have these
assessments you know at the beginning of
the end of the process but then what
else do we have going on
we have UCLA academies and it's to
support a lot of faculty we have a
faculty part work with the CLA quite a
bit for putting workshops and Saturday
academies for our other faculty there's
talk of actually with our qtp if we find
the money that's a big challenge putting
together something like a CLA across the
curriculum where faculty would receive
stipends for incorporating clas and
meaningful ways in their class the
reinforcement for our students comes
through CLA in the classroom so you know
they come in as entering freshmen for
example and they see a CLA performance
status they have no idea what they're
saying they some of them don't even look
at the documents but then they get into
their Freshman Seminar class and their
Freshman Seminar class instructor says
you remember that exercise that you did
here's what you were actually doing it
here's how they graded it
let's take a look at this and then
they're in my critical thinking classes
freshman as well and I haven't do
anywhere from two to five different C
exercises and then perhaps they get into
a major early on and they take a survey
class and they see a CLA of their when
they see that somebody's writing class
now they actually transition into the
majors moving towards the follow-up
assessments and they start encountering
CLA assignments in some of the more
foundational classes and then they're
also going to see in the capstone
classes and those capstone classes are
going to be getting them ready for that
exit exceeded that's where they'll
actually take that's the LA the other
part of the puzzle is the core review
committees
become a quaint active in putting
together robust committees to rethink
what counts as critical thinking what
counts as ethics and civic engagement
with councils global literacy and the
CLA and his writing
so this is again where Provost thinks of
it and so I think the same way so when I
did the webinar anything we had to put
it although acknowledgments and it's
kind of bid to think about Carnegie
Corporation helped us out a lot with it
and the CLA in the classroom accounts
great education to them then a lot of it
was internal
if you want to use the CLA and
meaningful way in your university in the
classroom you have to have the faculty
development people involved you have to
chief academic officer like Provost
buying into it and you also need
entities that will say hey we're going
to work with this I got there there's a
learning curve and you may make mistakes
if you look at those reports that we
have in our digital Commons
they're very uneven some some of the
people clearly understood that they're
working with some of them it's a little
bit easier if you were to do that we
were to generate new reports now gives
you the dramatic difference
yeah that's part of our institutional
history we used to have a center for
innovation in teaching and learning that
was closed by the General Administration
because bunch of cuts and certain
cutting centers to get in there and so
we definitely took what resources were
left after it's got it and we created an
office of faculty development that has
to carry on exactly the same tasks but
somewhat less resources but we're you
know we're doing pretty good things
what sentiment to be over violence the
issues of credibility and politics now
that's a that's admittedly a big issue
we have the national seal it by this one
marker that we but that's looking at the
rate of improvement of our students it's
not giving us a snapshot of where our
students are at any given time the way
that our institutional my personal I
think that we do have problems with
reliability and most problems stem from
faculty who don't have enough experience
with the CLA and the rubrics doing the
great one of the things I'm trying to do
about that this semester section I put
together a workshop I'll be giving a few
weeks specifically on rubrics are great
for a faculty but you know you know that
sort of thing
who goes to those workshops it's the
faculty
the faculty who are less committed less
interested they're still gonna be
grading erratically so you know do they
get compensated
it depends for the rising junior and
entering freshmen what we've done so far
is we had stipends the participating
faculty members got to in her box as a
coordinator at 400 bucks we didn't put
together what I think we should have
done to put in place performance
managers that had to do that before you
can paid anything we didn't so some
people off a lot of work while grading
and some people did point to frankly
fairly underlined
yeah yeah well you know how it is if you
want to get things done on title three's
timeline so time and effort reports need
to be in by the sir so for the entering
freshmen expedition we have to get all
that done so the rising junior it's not
a specter problem that in my rising
treated record advanced reports and
recommendations about how to
institutionalize some things that should
personally I think that if those things
are put in place and other walls then
you would have some some good measure of
reliable and you know the strategy of
using official you might say an
institutional ceilings side by side
some sort of things in place to make
sure
luckily I make one oh and I like wide
views on the reliability of our grading
process does not represent the winners
solely my own so especially since I'm 18
I got evidence any other questions and
anybody who's interested in the
well thanks for last name again please
Oh Sakura let's see
you